my name is Isaac palao check me out on
the bootle Kev
podcast yo bootle Kev podcast man
special guest in here my guy Isaac poo
is in the building welcome welcome
welcome thanks for having me for people
who don't know uh this guy is an
incredible artist incredible painter uh
you've seen his works if you are a fan
of
Griselda uh would you say that you're
cuz you have like a signature style it's
like it is it is it realism with your
own
twist cuz I don't I know that there's
like you know words for certain styles
of painting well the foundation of my
work is definitely realism it's uh
figurative
um but in the last like I don't know
four or five years of it introducing
more Street
contemporary modern stuff towards you
know mixing it with the realism um like
you'll have like a real like like some
realism and then like the the smiley
face yeah yeah yeah that's part of like
you know that's a spin of contemporary
mixing with the classical realism that I
do I do a lot of
uh Renaissance type of imagery or
religious iconography and I'll mix that
with some Street [__] you know it's
mixing it with maybe some spray paint um
oil pastels kind of introducing a new
element to it giving some layer depth
and texture uh that's that's been in
recent years though but the foundation
of my work is is definitely realism how
long have you like been a full-time
artist I would say
since since the beginning of 2020 that's
that's when you were like all in yeah
there was there you already you making
money before 2020 though yeah for sure
but it 2020 was like that was the
pivoting moment that's when things
really cracked off was that uh cu cu
obviously for people who don't know you
uh if you have seen any of these
paintings that you've done there's like
the third eye and yeah that's kind of
like a signature Isaac thing right and
and uh we were just talking you just
dropped a Tupac print uh how long ago
did you do that painting I did that
painting January of 2017 that was that
was the first piece that I did uh
incorporating a third eye and it kind of
like started I I ended up doing a whole
series based off of it because it became
really popular and then um so did a
whole show a whole body of work
surrounding that didn't think it was
going to take off as much as it did but
um you know when Wes picked up the the
concept it really blew up Westside gun
for people who don't know yeah so
Westside gun saw that painting and then
just contacted you and I you know he's
got this this condo in in Phoenix that's
just like a little Art Museum it's got
so many of your pieces in it yeah and
I've been to Buffalo to his store and
your stuff's in there yeah he's got a
gang of my [__] for sure how many
paintings has he got off you
probably north of 30 now damn yeah he's
probably he's got a lot he's got a few
sculptures couple of small pieces ton of
prints for you like uh you know how like
I feel like when you had when you do
something like the third eye thing you
didn't know obviously that it was going
to change change things for you no not
at all it it's funny cuz I get I talk
about that situation quite a bit and
still to this day I I had no idea I was
just I I so the story the way it goes is
I was in college in in uh Vegas and I
dropped out where you go to UNLV yeah I
was going to UNLV I was technically
studying art but you know I lived right
by UNLV their art programs are ass so I
looked off of a damn like right by the
Blueberry Hill restaurant off a trop
okay I was on no that was on Flamingo it
was on Flamingo and um it was over there
somewhere but shout out to Vegas you're
you're uh more like Northern you're like
more Northern right more Northeast I was
no I was like right behind UNLV so I was
like Flamingo like right by Blueberry
Hill that restaurant that's like I was I
was I was living in South though like
like more Henderson I lived on U Eastern
and Sunset okay yeah yeah right across
the street from McCarron Molly M's old
house yeah when it was McCarron I think
they call it something else now I think
it's still McCarron no cuz I tried to
look it up really and it's like some
other name yeah it's just stupid you
were going to school for art
which is a weird thing I feel like when
people say I go to school for art I'm
like really I was majoring in Fine Art
but when I got there I quickly realized
that their art programs aren't really
[__] you know that they got feel like a
hustle yeah not not a purposeful Hustle
but there's certain people when they say
they they like this is their major I'm
like I mean do you want to be an artist
cuz are they going to teach you how to
be like like I might teach you like
technique or like history or something
but like I feel like you either got the
sauce or you don't yeah I you know I I I
wasn't even planning on going to school
I wanted to go to Pasadena Art Center
that's where most people aspire to go to
when they want to learn you know more
contemporary stuff um kind of further
and expand their Horizons but I went to
please you know my ex's parents my
parents and I it was just I just sort of
fell into it I was like all right [__]
it I guess I'm going to go to school you
know school Shut everybody up and still
kind of do what got the little college
experience um but you know when I got to
when I when I started going to school I
was already really proficient in drawing
my my portraits and pencil were already
pretty realistic and I already had a
sense of um a backstory to my work and
you know I had taken art history in high
school and I already I felt like I was
already uh I had already built a solid
foundation as as you know young artist I
already had a style I was already
drawing pretty good i' had already been
exhibiting my work I mean I started
exhibiting my work when I was 10it so by
the time I was 18 so you already great
at yeah I mean I wouldn't say great I
just already had uh almost a 10year head
start um so I I felt like school was
just kind of unnecessary I already knew
where I what I wanted I already knew
where I was uh for the most part headed
I just figured you know [__] it maybe
I'll no no maybe I'll learn the business
side of it I should have studied uh
business um management or maybe even you
know theater cuz you know I was doing
acting too so I probably would have
benefited more from that but yeah I was
there for about 2 years I dropped out
and when I dropped out I started
painting I I wasn't painting up until
yeah cuz that's I always you'll see
people who are really good at drawing
and then they end up getting into
painting or tattooing yeah and I'm
always like yo that feels like such a
far thing to be good at that and then
like cuz it's different tools like yeah
it's a different way of making art
that's for sure um but you know my dad's
a a pretty uh well-known artist too in
in in the LA community and his work is
some of the real the most incredible
pencil realism I've seen I would I would
argue he's one of the best pencil
artists that I've ever seen yeah um so
by the time I was 18 I was already
drawing pretty close to that that level
we exib our
and for and I kind into shadows and so I
already knew then that I wanted to Veer
off and do you know something different
that made me stand out so that I had my
own identity and then painting seemed
like the right fit and and luckily it
you know I did because it was the right
fit it was able to create big work uh
work that people responded to people
it's so hard to sell pencil drawings
people respond more to paintings the the
texture no for sure I feel like if
someone's going to spend money on
something spend money on a painting
there there aren't pencil drawings that
you know are um as coveted as paintings
art you know if you look at the history
of of the auction houses and all the
pieces of art that is ever sold for the
most amount of money it's all paintings
it's all paintings or sculptures right
drawings they they fall short of it you
know there's some drawings I mean if
you're [__] Da Vinci and you got like
one yeah if you're if you're that name
and you're hey this is a da Vinci hand
hand drawn thing people are going to
spend money on that but it's yeah to
many you know that's priceless but um
yeah pencil drawings aren't they're
really hard to to sell in the in in the
art World um so I knew you know painting
was definitely my calling when I and I
it honestly was pretty natural I started
painting picked up a bunch of cheap
tools from [__] Michaels I think and
just started painting my ass off I
painted every day for a whole [__]
year wow and that was like my foury year
col college experience on my own you
know I painted every day with Bob Ross
playing in the background and that was
like I had like a it was like a you know
eight 10 years SM of practice smashed
into one right one year so after one
full year I painted all every day of uh
2016 and then January 2017 I decided to
paint the PAC portrait I'd always wanted
to do a portrait of Tupac that's one of
my my Idols growing up one of my
Inspirations cuz I do music too so as
someone that was you know a a Lyricist
Enthusiast that's someone that I've
always admired and um I wanted to to do
a portrait of him that was different
from everything else that i' had seen my
dad you know had done a few portrait of
Tupac that I felt were [__] beautiful
I was like I wanted to do something that
that competed right right right and and
um it didn't dawn on me right away to do
a third eye it that just happened Midway
I was already halfway into painting it
and I was I at the time I was going
through through a lot of [__] with my
parents with my ex I was struggling
dropped out of college I was you know
doing tattoos on the side to pay rent
selling a couple of so you doing tattoos
too I've been doing tattoos since I was
15 oh [__] okay yeah so and I started
doing that when I lived in Texas I just
picked that [__] up randomly so you know
I was doing that as a side hustle and um
selling drawings doing commissions on
the side and working you know some
part-time jobs that were [__] ass
doing like maintenance or desk work
[__] retail yeah so dude at one point
I had like I got hired on at like three
different retail places at once it was
like [__] Bed Bath and Beyond coals
and [__] guest were you work did you
work all three at the same time or did
you just pick like ah [__] which one do
I go to well I I did the training for
each one and I think you get paid off of
the training right yeah so I just
collected like two three [__] weeks
of pay and I just was like all right I'm
out like they were all like what the
[__] like yeah so I did that before call
centers I used to do that call centers I
get the call center job I just do the
training and then quit yeah it was just
on to the next one it was pretty easy
for me to get hired I would I would
apply to like 30 [__] places at once
get pick which you know call backs and
then um I worked at gas and Steve Madden
for a cool minute and then and then left
that [__] too so yeah you know I was I
was doing a bunch of side hustles just
to pay rent and to support my my you
know and like my painting Journey cuz
that [__] ain't cheap you know I can
imagine supplies paint brushes canvases
are not like canvases are what like 25
bucks oh no dude they go for yeah I mean
if you're buying small canvases but my
yeah my large canvases are like 200
bucks especially when it's quality stuff
and I P I paint on wood panels so it's
it's a little more yeah cuz like you
could probably get like a cheap canvas
Michaels and SP like 80 bucks something
you can tell the difference in art it's
important to use I'm good [__] like I'm
always impressed by people trying to
make good art with cheap equipment you
know cheap brushes cheap paint that
stuff matters you know I I remember I
was I was using that stuff and then when
I started buying more expensive brushes
more expensive paint I realized the
difference oh dude it's like the
comparison I suppose is like a
microphone exactly you know using analog
equipment versus like you know this doll
[__] and then and then having like good
like good good quality [__] and then you
you really can see it in the work um so
yeah for a year you know I painted every
day was using a bunch of cheap [__]
started you know immediately selling
work it was crazy cuz I I had started
Selling paintings right away oh [__]
like way quicker like how much were they
going for your first
ones I want to
say the first painting that I had
exhibited was uh a a portrait of a skull
with a sombrero and I I had shown it at
one of my dad's events A Day of the Dead
event I sold it for like 500 bucks and
that was like the most I had ever sold a
piece for in a gallery setting cuz
before you were doing the pencil stuff I
was doing pencil stuff that was going
for you know $2 $300 and it was easy it
was it was easy to move those CU they
were so affordable but then the
paintings completely switched it up for
me because you know I was it was quickly
seeing how they were going and within
art you know it's people always ask me
like how do you appraise a work how do
you determine what a work costs I mean
I've been exhibiting my work since I was
10 so you know I built my work up to
what it is now at a very like early
short price stage yeah where my work was
going for you know 1002 200 every year
it just goes up 100 well it's also just
like whatever someone's willing to pay
right cuz sometimes you'll see a piece
of art and you're like I mean yeah at
the end of the day art is really worth
nothing but to some people it's worth
everything so yeah it's worth what
anybody's willing to pay but I'm talking
about you know in in the gallery setting
on a secondary Market you know someone
buys your work and resells it so do
people do that a lot with your stuff
they'll buy and flip yeah mostly with
the prints not not so with the orig you
know what I see that too cuz those
Griselda fans they love buying and
flipping [__] man the the pray for Paris
joint that I did you know that print
went for 100 bucks and it's on eBay for
like three grand Jesus so you know it's
how many prints did you do well whenever
I do [__] with Wes it's you know it's
really up to him I
mean collaborative well it's really his
choice I have very say like very little
say in what he does you know at the at
the uh the first few [__] that we did
together it was it was an addition of
100 and then he quickly started doing
additions of 187 Mak Sense on brand so
you know and I think he it only recently
he started doing like
250 you know with the with the Virgil
stuff and the roll out with and then you
pray for me but um yeah I mean that that
that piece was extremely popular and you
know it's going for you know I mean so
much more than what it I wonder like
when you and like cuz cuz obviously
Westside guns got so much to do with
like giving you exposure yeah um do you
like charge him if he wants a piece like
he wants Thurman Thomas with an ey Bray
okay okay you know I don't know yeah big
bro he he pays um you know I I my
relationship with Wes is is a unique one
and I think at after the first year you
know know we we did stuff together I
think it quickly became more family
based than anything it it became tighter
than I had expected and you know
whenever we do [__] it's I we don't even
talk numbers you know he he'll text me
yo I I need this by yesterday I'm like
all right I'm on it and the numbers will
be you know we'll figure out the numbers
later right right with every with
anybody else it's it's different you
know what I'm saying cuz obviously Wes
is you know my dror Dre I mean like
that's my you know he put me on for sure
and I'll always keep that relationship
like that because I feel like I owe it
to him to just you know I mean whatever
he needs he knows I'm there so but yeah
I mean it's crazy how that that
relationship even you know came about
like I said after that first year
painting I did that portrait of Pac
third eye thing cracked off and then
some of my homeboys who grew up with uh
Diddy's kids hit me up and they're like
yo you should do a portrait of Biggie
and we'll move it to puff so I did
approach to biggie I was at the time I
was living in Vegas I [__] drove 4
hours just to drop that [__] off in Hy
Hills at Diddy's crib wow so that was uh
you know a stamp of of approval so Diddy
bought the biggie painting it it it's a
little trickier than that you know what
I'm saying I actually never even met
Diddy a lot of people think it was like
that is it hung up at his house
somewhere yeah no for sure it's it's
it's hung in a studio in homie Hills oh
nice what the crazy [__] is that you
know I never met Diddy right but he has
posted that [__] painting so many
times I mean that that painting is hung
in the recording studio in his house
right A lot of people have recorded in
there so many people background and so
many pictures many people have posted my
painting on on Instagram I remember Joey
Badass was like raving about it you know
um this one was kind of this is kind of
sentimental but when nipsy was working
on Victory lap he there's a picture he
posted with him and puff side by side
and you see my big portrait in the
background and I was like damn I was
like I felt like my spirit was there a
little bit during that process um and I
never got to meet dude and I would have
loved to cuz you know that was one of my
well that's got to be one of your
paintings eventually you got to do the
nip one man oh well I I did a nipy
portrait a while back for uh the real
Street Fest oh I was hosting that yeah I
was um I it was it was like I had a a
friend who knew the people over at a
what was it 1500 sound is that what it
is or 1500 Sound Academy oh yeah yeah
1500 and nothing guys yeah yeah and it's
like George piche and [__] so they had a
thing going on with like Fender and I
had did a a portrait nip to put on
display at their Booth so I had that
that was the only portrait I did of him
but you know I'm not really big into
doing
um like dead celebrities I I really only
do that [__] if it's if if it the
opportunity makes sense if someone's
commissioning it I won't just I did that
already I did that so much early on that
I realized I didn't want to base my
identity off of painting dead
celebrities it's not I'm not I'm not no
you've you've done like [__] Josh Allen
yeah you know that's that's on West you
know that's like Wes's Cur curation and
and what he wants but I won't do that
consciously I've only done it a couple
of times and and if I do it that's
because it it really means a lot to me
to do it you know I wanted to build my
career off of my own [__] I wanted to
build my my art career off of
uh an original style of work of versus
being you know oh that dude just paints
it's so easy celebrities do you see that
[__] all the time I'm not I think a lot
of people misconstrued me with other
artists like I'm not a IG artist if IG
disappeared you still are going to be
I'm still going to be like you know it's
kind of like modeling right it's like
you could be an Instagram model but
could you like do print work yeah do you
have an agent you know what I'm saying
it's different there's a lot of
[__] that don't exist in that
world but they exist on the social media
platform so if that sh disappears it's
like a lot of these Tik tokers you know
a lot of these Tik Tok [__] had
to find a a path cuz when Tik Tok
started to fall off you know they they
had to do something so either they got
into music they got acting they
definitely started doing a bunch of that
I was going to say have you had anybody
who just straight stolen your style I
mean all the time yeah that [__] happens
weekly you know what I mean people tag
me in [__] that people will do this like
thir [__] or smiley face [__] you know I
remember um fashion Nova had dropped the
whole line and they dropped some third
eyy Smiley [__] and I tried to hit them
up um I was actually going to go over
one of their Billboards they had down in
Hollywood I was going to [__] blast
that [__] that been hard um but I got a
fear of height so I'm not doing that
[__] that [__] was way too high I
actually went there like twice it's on
the second time I was like all right I'm
going to go up there but I was like the
billboard was right above a like a fence
that had the [__] like the spikes and
[__] backwards yeah I'm like I'm not
risking this [__] final yeah I'd rather
hit like one of the home boy to [__]
go hit this [__] yo they steal so much
yeah they them Sheen like all those
companies dude they steal so much from
like small like small artists small
creators like small clothing lines even
they'll steal a [__] clothing line
design there's no way they didn't see my
[__] dude it was a third eyye smiley
face where else you're going to see that
[__] with like with like like drippy
like exactly my [__] everything it's
crazy and I was like every body was
tagging me in it I was like these
[__] you know what I'm saying
I'm like like it's cool I've had a lot
of people you know try to bite this [__]
and maybe maybe you know it's possible
that [__] just got the same
idea it's possible that they you know
I'm you know what it is too is you your
work's so popular people will see it and
not even care to see like oh what is
this what is this from they just see it
and then they're like oh we're just
going to replicate without thinking of
of you [__] will get inspired
and they'll run and do their own [__] I
mean I would have loved to even just you
know had the conversation of doing a
legit collab it was like bro we can make
so much more by just doing this
legitimately you know what I mean but um
yeah people bite this [__] all the time
and it was funny when I when when Wes
hit me up you know he he immediately
responded to the third eye [__] that was
what he liked and he goes um dude it's
the craziest [__] because I had read I
had discovered who Wes and Conway was in
an article about them sh signing a sh
and at the time you know I was following
a lot of hip-hop Pages you know kind of
trying to stay up to date with what was
going on um cuz I started putting a lot
of music out in like 2018 and you know
writing a lot and um so I was trying to
stay up to date and I saw that article
and I looked into their music I was like
damn these [__] are dope had no
idea who they were I was like these
dudes obviously like I probably had the
same impression as everybody else right
away it spoke wuang but I was like I
thought these dudes were like some old
heads that I just never never heard of
right right right um and then fast
forward that was like in June June or
July of 2017 fast forward to September I
get a DM from West because hip hop DX
posted my Tupac painting and he was like
Yo dude he's like I [__] with your [__]
he was like you know I just bought a new
crib I want to acquire some work he
asked what I had you know nothing really
spoke to him at the time and he was like
let me think about it and then he hits
me back up like a month or two later
he's like I'm about to drop an album at
the top of 2018 and I want you to do the
cover and I was like all right bet like
we could do that and it was the first
time I had ever been you know offered to
do a like a an album cover like
something legit yeah and uh I was like
what do you have in mind and he goes I
want to do a portrait of Chris benan
with the third eye and I was like oh
[__] like all right we can run that so
and I was already building uh a body of
work for a show that year so when I did
that cover and it came out it just
elevated every the whole body work that
I was doing yeah Hy Beast picked it up
and they were talking about it so that
was it was a crazy cosign and um but
nobody really at the time I wasn't like
I didn't have that big of a IG following
actually I didn't have IG follow I
probably had like 10,000 followers so
very few people right right so when they
saw my third eye series a lot of people
thought I was biting Wes they just
thought that I was they're like realize
that you're yeah like I would get a lot
of people in my comments being like damn
this [__] looks like Westside gun [__]
or this mother
uck I'm like and I just like at the
beginning I would have to like explain
to people and then I just started now
when it h it still happens when it
happens I'm just like man shit's funny
cuz I'm like these [__] stupid
they just don't know but that but that's
why it's like you know my Ig is [__]
like from top to bottom is just filled
with Westside [__] so I'm like how do
you not know you know I mean like it's
been six years now like how do you how
are you not caught up but um yeah it's
funny so you know a lot of people
because Wes put that [__] out a lot of
people started copying it the smile
especially the smiley face thing you
know I'll see a lot of people doing
portraits of Wes with like a third eye
with like smiley faces and [__] in the
background and and it wasn't like a
conscious thing like I'm going to paint
third eyes and smiley faces and that's
what's going to that's what's going to
hit it just it just happened you know
and people responded to it really well
want to give a shout out to our family
our new sponsor shout out to Munchies
man it's
Thanksgiving we love the munchies baby
all right want to give a shout out to
munchies the market leader in the hemp
and cannabis space of course offering
you federally legal award-winning hemp
products that are comparable to your
favorite cannabis products all right and
it get shipped straight to your door and
check this out the craziest sale of the
year so much going on so many products I
love the strawberry dream gummies let's
pop these boys open all right this was
dope the biggest sale of the Year 40%
off any order 40% off any order of $60
or more right now if you go to their
website go to delt munchies. comom use
the promo code bootleg or bootleg Kev
you can use either one of those bootleg
bootleg cab all together you're going to
get 40% off any order this is what's
dope about their gummies all right their
gummies are so good 100 milligrams per
gummy so you see all these there's 1,000
milligrams in the box they're vegan
they're made with real fruit and the
flavors are crazy you've seen the
strawberry dream they also got the apple
berry neck and this one right here the
tropical passion all right and let's not
forget that they also got the Vapes for
you yeah that's right this is the grape
R runs uh grape jelly runs rather oh my
God that packaging looks good I'm about
to also they got the Strawberry
Shortcake and they got the pre-rolls the
double doinks man these ones right here
are the Lemon Cherry gelato that's a
hybrid um and look you can get 40% off
right now 40% off right now um all you
have to do is go to Delta munchies . use
that promo code bootleg Kev or bootleg
uh you'll see it down below all right
and get 40% off your order of $6 or more
now this is important because the sale
ends November 30th so head on over to
delt munchies. get you some of that
slushie juice these are very good four G
blend of live resin thcp and Delta 8 you
can get a 5,000 hits out of this bad boy
plus free lanyard in every bag dunes.com
bam all right wait we got to stop the
interview this is an emergency my bookie
just sent me an email this week is
Thanksgiving week and we have an
emergency offer sign up at
mybookie.ag we're going to have so much
football to bet on Thanksgiving how
about all the NBA that's going to be
happening on Black Friday oh football
weekend is going to be crazy and right
now this is very exclusive to the bootle
C podcast they're doing a
110% deposit bonus
that's right this bonus offer is 110%
deposit match up to
$1,100 that means if you deposit $1,000
you will get
$1,100 for free put right into your
account to gamble with what are we doing
go to my bookie right now my bookie
right now sign up use the promo code
bootleg and this only is going on until
November 26th that's Sunday all right so
from now till Sunday if you sign up in
my bookie you're going to get
110% deposit match uh bonus all right
that means you put in a th000 you're
going to get ,100 you put in 100 you're
going to get $110 did I do that right my
M's [__] all right but listen shout
out to mybookie all right sign up
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
this is so exclusive y'all this is only
happening this week so make sure you
sign up if you like to gamble like me
let's get this money baby I was going to
say uh for you like like I know that you
know you just did a commission piece for
peasy the fat the fat joke uh piece like
if somebody hits you uh you don't have
to give us your business but like what
like what's the conversation start at if
you if they want to commission at peace
with you well I mean yeah let's just say
some dude off the street who just wants
you to paint yeah I mean I'll put you on
game I mean you know I get hit up the
art game is just so interesting to me
because you hear like there's these apps
you can buy pieces of art you can buy
Shar of art there's the gallery game
there's so many like it's just like it's
it's kind of like the music game there's
just so many different yeah I think I
think during 2020 though I kind of um it
it things change I'm telling you like a
lot of [__] changed for me in 2020 that
there was a lot of things that happened
that elevated everything that I was
doing and I kind of beat the gallery
system especially the galleries that I
was working with at the time um I up
until you know then I had never had
representation I had exhibited in my
work in tons of galleries
you
kind you know kind ofi a lot of St um
during that time because when pray for
Paris came out I had a lot of attention
uh having done the alternate cover that
Virgil did yeah so a lot of people uh
you know had their eyes on me and I sold
a lot of work by myself you know I I
never had a art dealer never had an
advisor or any type of manager
representative so you know my my process
was very like like it became on like on
some trapping [__] you know that's
that's how like a lot of the [__] that's
what it felt like like I felt like the
last four or five years I've been
trapping my [__] just straight straight
up like there's no the formula is so
simple like I don't even know how to
explain it to people in simpler terms
you know people think that there's some
sort of crazy formula and I'm like nah
dude it just sort of happened where it
it was pretty it's organic you know West
hit me when West hit me up it was as
simple as yo dude I want to work with
you and I was a fan of him and I was
like yeah let's do it you know there was
no contract there was no business
meeting it was like what you what do
what do you want to run you know sent me
some some images I was like all right
let's run this one we did it gave him a
price and that was it and then and
that's just is super straightforward you
know like so I don't do projects for
just anybody I so not anybody can just
no like in the beginning maybe but I
quickly started to realize that you know
I had the opportunity to say no to a lot
of [__] you know in the beginning CU
what is like if you say yes to something
what is the time that it takes to put
one of your paintings together it just
depends on the project it depends on you
know what I got going on at the time if
I'm already working on a bunch of [__]
I'm saying like in terms of just like
hours man hours actual painting I mean
it you know it depends on how big the
piece how much detail there is I mean I
can bust out a painting pretty quickly
if I really put everything aside say the
Fat Joe Wi
well Fat Joe is um that's a 5x5 painting
5T by 5et I think I did that [__] in
like like 30 Days Like A month's time
but I was taking breaks there was stuff
that was happening in between but you
know it's like when Wes hits me up and
he's like yo I need this [__] by
yesterday I'm like on a three-day
timeline like I got so you'll tweak out
and just finish dude straight 12-hour
days just back to back nonstop yeah like
when I did a um when I did the Jordan
and Virgil portrait I did those both in
like three days like collectively yeah
like Virgil took me like one day and
then Jordan took me two days but that's
that's because I had to I don't think it
really matters how fast or long it takes
for someone to create something um I
could work very quickly just because I
know like once I start I'm locked in
it's like it's like a rapper it's like
you know when they jump into a studio
it's like they already got the material
laid out just give them a [__] [__]
beat and once they're in they're in you
know what I mean it's not like uh you
know and then you got some of these
artists who take you know a year or two
years to make a project cuz they're
they're like taking their time they're
Reminiscing on it with me I could just
jump into it I'm already especially when
Wes hits me up cuz when Wes hits me up
it's like it's Synergy like that energy
just I get locked into it and then I'm
already I'm already on I'm already on it
you know there's no there's nothing
that's going to uh slow me down when I'm
working on his projects but um yeah I I
you know I don't take on just any
projects I quickly started to say no to
a lot of [__] you know I keep the I keep
the the the the group of people that
collect my [__] is very tight you know
there is a weight list you know I there
there is a a process sort of an
evaluation process to get my [__] now oh
that's sick you know what I mean and I
mean that's a good place to be in yeah
it is but you know it all and and I get
it you know I know everybody wants it
but that's why I started you know doing
the prints allows people to acquire my
work on on a scale that's you know it's
like not everybody's going to afford a
$30 $440,000 painting but you know the
prints it allows the work to be
accessible for everybody and that's that
was you know important for me to to
establish because I want everybody to
have my [__] yeah you know what I mean
but the the the original [__] it's like
that's you know that's reserved for you
got to come it it's like you got to come
correct you I get a lot of people
that'll that'll hit me up and they
they'll assume that the work is I mean I
really don't care what the price of [__]
goes for but you know it took me a long
time to get to where I'm at and you know
I I it's hard to explain that to
everybody and then when people hit me up
and they're like oh what's your we going
for and I'll give them a number and
they're like damn that shit's crazy like
I thought you know I got to wait a while
and I'm like well you know you it's cool
that you didn't know it's fine but I'm
like you know what do you expect like
you're hitting me up because you you see
that West [__] with me pey [__] with
me I'm doing [__] for [__] Benny I'm
doing [__] for all these people and
doing collabs with it own and so I'm
like come on what do you expect like
don't you know what I mean that's why I
got certain things pinned on my page so
[__] know like you're not going
to go to so and so you know super
established and just well yeah you're
not going to go to like ask Timberland
for a beat and then be surprised when he
tries to hit you upside the head yeah
and I'm like I'm I wouldn't even you
know so but it takes people to ask so
they know so you know what I mean but
that's why I'm like you know I I don't
know people I guess they don't really do
their research I mean you could find the
price of [__] un likee artsy you know my
shit's there you know what's artsy is
that kind of like artsy is a Marketplace
for to sell art you know I got a I got a
bunch of art listed there through some
of my dealers that sell my stuff so you
know there's prices there I mean and and
you know it's the [__] that I do with
Wes is not is not a mystery you know
what I mean I mean the prices are there
he talks about it you but at the end of
the day I really don't think the price
of [__] matters that's just what it is
but you know I I I think um it's what
matters more is like the projects that
I'm working on I try to keep it very
curated again I'm not going to just do
anything I've had people come at me with
you know a bag and they're like yo I
want you to do an album cover I'm like I
I don't even know your music like that I
don't even [__] with you know with I
don't know anything about you so I'm
like I'm not going to just do it because
you're waving a bag in my face like I
don't need the money like that you know
I'm more I'm more um what makes sense
yeah I'm concerned about exactly like
does it does it align with what I'm
doing and you know cuz some people will
hit me up and they'll be like oh we want
you to do some like Alec Monopoly type
[__] I'm like well then go get a [__]
Alec monopo that [__] got I mean shout
out to that guy who's obviously really
successful but that that [__] is so like
what is that like yeah I me it's to me
like you know that [__] is very like if
you go to a scammer's house you might
see some fake Alec Monopoly [__] yeah
for sure you know it's like you're not
going to go it's different it's just
different yeah you're not going to
[__] you know no one's going to ask
timberin to make him a [__] you know
Murder beats type
be or some [__] so yeah you know I get a
lot of that too someone asked you to
make something like that I get that all
the time or or they'll I'll get a lot of
like you know sometimes I will humor the
the situ you know I'll always hear
people out and see what they want just
because I just I don't know I like I
just that's just me personally I always
hear people out and and sometimes you
know if the opportunity is something
that pequs my interest or I believe in
it then you know I'll consider it but a
lot of times I'll get some goofy ass
like you know idea that people want to
do and I'm like yeah I'm not doing that
like I'm I'm not doing that [__] or like
people will want me to do some [__] like
like um I'm not going to say no names
but cuz I don't want to sound like I'm
hating or clowning but I had a home
homeboy hit me up uh to do a project and
I'm a fan and he was like I want to do a
I want to just for his house you know I
want to commission a piece and he had
this crazy ass like idea about doing a
portrait of him on like some like Viking
battle [__] I was like dude I don't
paint [__] like that like you know what
I'm saying you're like asking me to
paint like Frank fretta I don't paint
like that [__] like um you see
my work you know what I'm saying so like
if you got something that falls into
what I do then you know then I can do it
but you're asking me to paint some like
fantasy mystery [__] that I don't like
even I'm not even on yeah so um and I
think people who aren aren't that
learned about art and how artists you
know operate they just assume oh this
dude can paint he can paint anything and
it's like I'm not going to just PT you
also don't want to you also don't want
to paint anything exactly it's like
asking [__] Tarantino to do like a
love film or some [__] do like a you
feel me like it's like you're not going
to ask it like nah he's going to make
what he makes because he's mastered that
you know so what's been your favorite
painting so far cuz you have so many
dope ones that Mike Tyson when recently
was hard obviously the Elizabeth Taylor
one's probably my favorite I got that on
a hoodie that shit's clean yeah you know
I think it's really hard to I I have a a
a deep relationship with all the work
that I've ever created I think you know
Tupac has a special place in my heart
because of what it's done for me I think
um the My Mona Lisa Master Copy that I
did you know was a a big pivoting moment
for me cuz I grew up studying Italian
Renaissance I grew up studying the
Baroque Period neoclassicism and all
that [__] so uh Da Vinci was someone
that I did that's like my alltime
favorite that's like my Jesus Christ you
know I pray to Da Vinci when I painted
so when I did that Mona Lisa Master Copy
that was like uh a challenge for me to
see if can I really push myself to paint
can am I just you know am I lying to
myself is this something that I can
actually do when I got there I was like
I guess I can paint you know pretty
[__] good so it was like you know it
was for me so then I started retracting
my steps and getting more loose with it
it was kind of like a Picasso thing I'm
not saying a Picasso but you know by the
time Picasso was 14 he was able to paint
L Rembrandt and then it took him a
lifetime to [__] you know find that
style and it wasn't up until he
developed cubism to what it is now um
that took you know gave him his voice
and I think that you know learning the
foundation of portraiture and figurative
art and realism gave me the uh Leisure
to be able to go in the direction that
I've gone and and get so loose with my
my breaststroke you know a lot of people
a lot of my aspiring artist homies will
ask me you know how do how did I find
that you know that stroke where I was
able to get so loose and make it work
cuz a lot of people think that you know
just because you can paint or draw real
that's that's what's going to make you
successful it's not the case it's like
rappers thinking just cuz they could rap
[__] fast that they're going to be m&
t or even like just cuz you're like
super lyrical if you if you are not if
you have like no flow or you're hard to
hear it's like you feel me dude I know
there's some [__] rappers that can
spit better than 90% of no but the
music's not palatable like you might be
able to put some cool words together but
like that doesn't make you good at
rapping right it it's makes you good at
writing there's flavor you know what I'm
saying you know there's there's soul to
it you can't I tell people all the time
like I'm not going to go around claiming
that I'm an artist and I'm prolific and
I'm making work that's going to be
revered in 500 years I don't know maybe
not but what I do know is that art you
can't teach that [__] you either got it
or you don't but you have to put in the
hours to discover it you know what I
mean you have to find it I think a lot
of people can make art I think they just
have to live enough life in order to
achieve right that ability right um you
know and I again I've been doing this
[__] since I was a kid so I've had a lot
of hours uh sharpening my blade but I've
also lived a lot of life in between then
that gave gave me the experience and
storytelling to talk about art is
storytelling so if you don't have enough
experience you're not going to have good
stories to tell you're not you know just
cuz you can [__] draw or paint so
good you're what are you going to paint
about you know you're just going to be
another one of these IG artists who are
doing portraits of celebrities or or
[__] that you know is is going to sell
that's like a commercial artist I
wouldn't consider myself commercial
artist because I paint what I want to
paint whether I think it's going to sell
or not um there is a narrative to my
work and fortunately you know I've built
a following that um understands the
story and they they pay attention to the
stories that I'm telling in the
narrative so they they read into that
and and stylistically they like the work
you know but um yeah I think I think man
it's so hard the the first pray for
Paris painting that I did really [__]
holds a special place in my heart you
know that really changed everything yeah
that smiley face [__] like that's what
really set my whole [__] off I think I
have that I have that on a t-shirt too
yeah that's that's the [__] that set
everything off dude that's it's like
this in 2020 when that [__] came out I
sold maybe like I don't know close to a
100 original paintings that year mhm I
bought my house off of that year that's
crazy and then the following year it
just developed even more and you know
again I probably sold anywhere between
two 300 works every year since then
crazy that's a lot of [__] work it's
a lot of pain that's a lot of work that
doesn't even include print sales merch
sales commissions or hand embellished
you know prints hand embellish prints
are you know those are I don't know if
you're familiar with what you have is a
hand embellish print so that you know
holds a little more value than just the
you know the large Edition print if I'm
doing an addition of a 100 I might do 10
hand embellish joints and you know touch
it with pastel or spray paint and those
are super limited cuz I'll only do no
more than 10 that makesense so that you
know including those prints Originals
like yeah the hustle in since 2020 21 22
and this year has been [__] monstrous
I was going to say uh hey what up y'all
we got to stop the interview tell you
about our good Folks at King pom that's
right let me tell you about King pom man
it's all we smoking over here what I
love about King pom CHP and Infused
flavor in each one of these These are
the margarita now this is kind of the
wave I've been on recently these
Margarita ones are [__] fire
no tobacco no nicotine straight raw
organic fresh leaves um and what's dope
is they got the tip you squeeze the tip
you hit one of these boys and you just
get hit with that flavor man you get hit
with that flavor no matter how big or
small the Palm is you know what I'm
saying this is what's dope too uh King
Palm if y'all don't know man they're one
of the leading Brands when it comes to
this real like organic smoke like that's
why I like them I like to smoke clean
nothing smokes cleaner than a King Palm
so if you're in your hood you're in your
neighborhood you're in your
[__] City your area wherever
you're at go to your local liquor store
they're going to have King poms all
right so pick them up there you can also
go to 7-Eleven or this is what I suggest
you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg this is what we're doing
50% off whatever you order they got so
much at King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our our listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party odd
Soxs baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsocks official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about odd Soxs they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah look
at those they just locked down Hasbro so
they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the drawers they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need odd Soxs official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Soxs to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it odd Sox official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview shout out to the homies over
at Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blueo work
well you don't take my word for it try
it for free for a month by using that
promo code bootleg right now blue has
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Calis uh it's all wrapped up into a
blue chewable form delivered right to
your doorstep in discreet packaging no
doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue Chu
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
fre free a month supply for free go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg
right now thank me later let's get back
to the interview if can you share with
us the most you've ever gotten for a
painting well the Last Supper joint the
$100,000 painting that one was great
that was that was from my show last year
you know and but I had you know who
bought that that's that's Wes's painting
that's Wes's okay but I had spoken to
Wes like 6 months prior to doing that
work and we already had the agreement
that it was his he have it at well I I
shipped it out to Atlanta okay um but I
think I think he I think he got a new
place and I think he pushed all the art
out of Atlanta and to put it somewhere
else so I'm not really sure how big was
that last last I heard it it was at like
Urban Necessities so in Vegas yeah I
think they probably had it there on view
some [__] I don't know how how big was
that painting 14 ft Jesus well 14 ft
wide is 1 it's 7 ft by 14 ft so the
DeMent the original that's so big yeah
the original mural is 14 by 30 like the
original Last original Last Supper mural
is 14 by 30 and I wanted mine I mine
needed to be proportionate so I just cut
it in half and did 7 by 14 or seven
Technic should have been 17 7 by 15 but
the you know I had to cut it down a
little bit I had to fit in my [__]
Studio that's massive dude how long did
that take you 4 days four days yeah that
was the so you saw the show that I did
last year the show called the New
Renaissance so I I had um it wait it
only took you four days to do that what
was the last piece that I was working on
for the show I had painted I had did 70
pieces for that for that exhibit and
that was the last one that I was working
on and I and I wanted it to be the last
one
because it I I needed to have all my
focus on it I was working on five
paintings at once just you know while
one's drying I'm working on the next one
and I did didn't want to do that with
that one that one had to be painted at a
certain pace and um yeah it was the same
situation it was like 12-hour days
nonstop boom boom boom just smashed it
out what is like for you like I feel
like there's so many talented artists
but there's you know I've seen like so
many people who I know who paint who are
dope but like for whatever reason you
know they they can't pop you know or
create the demand for the work for you
is there any advice you know you
obviously were putting position where
you had a light shine bright on you but
for somebody who's a struggling artist
who's very talented what would be the
advice you would give them in terms of
like how to kind of like try to their
best to make a living off of their
passion you know yeah um I mean it's
tough it you know I feel like a lot of
it has to do with being at the right
place at the right time yeah CU there's
a lot of talented artists that I know
people that I've known for years and
they're still you know in a trying to
pop off and I think um I think a lot you
know this is what I know for sure being
a a fine artist and having a career half
the battle is making good art and the
other battle is is being a good
networker CU and in like in every
business it's not what you know it's who
you know and what that where like the
gallery game comes in well it just you
know what relationships do you have cuz
as an artist you know there's a lot of
people who do make art a lot of people
that you see on social media they have
no idea how the real art World operates
they don't know nothing about the
galleries the art dealers the Au CU like
will you have like an art dealer shop
your pieces uh I mean I recently I
started working with multiple dealers
I've always had people that try to you
know what do they what do they do though
like are they like they have a clientele
they this is what yeah exactly they have
a clientele list that you know maybe
they have clients overseas and those
clients have built a relationship with
them and an art dealer or adviser's job
is to advise collectors what they should
own you know what I'm saying it's very
it's very C so they're almost like
selling it to them like hey this is you
you need this this is a good investment
there's I a lot of people collect art as
an investment I don't care for
collectors like that because I'm not
trying to sell [__] just for a bag and
I'm not I want to see someone reselling
my [__] 10 years down the road I want my
work to be uh in collections that are
going to get picked up by a [__]
Museum one day you know collections that
are going to be
alongside people that I admire or or a a
collection is is is really storytelling
it's like someone who collects shoes or
cars you know there's there's a reason
to collect all that [__] you know what
I'm saying there's a passion behind as
opposed to someone who just buys shoes
to flip them you feel me or someone who
you look at a lot of people's art
collections today they're going to have
you know [__] cause with Mami and
they're going to have like a [__] you
know print by I don't know some you know
some random you know contemporary
commercial artist and I'm not I'm not
Downing those artists I'm I'm I'm a big
fan of muracami and cause and Shephard
you know all these guys but just a lot
of people buy [__] just because of the
name that goes behind it it's it's know
what the value is you know what I'm
saying like you go to a [__]
like you go to like a 30-year-old
motherfucker's house and they got
everything is just dripped in like Bape
and cause and Mami trust me I've been in
a lot of those houses yeah and I'm like
bro you have no knowledge of like you
know curating your [__] like your [__]
looks like everybody's house like
[__] sneaker [__] resale looks
like round two you like the [__] is this
so for sure I think you know a person
who's a collector CU I collect art too I
collect other people's work and I
collect [__] that you know I I you know
obviously have a relationship with I
look into the story I what it means uh
stylistically how it you know fits in
with everything else that I have and the
relationships that I built with those
particular artists so in in my opinion I
feel like you know as a
collector yeah I want or as an artist I
want my work to go into collections that
are well curated and that are going to
last or even be talked about you know
you know what I'm saying like it's like
it's like Jay Leno's car collection how
many times do people talk about that
[__] for sure you know but there's a lot
of people that own 30 40 cars but no one
gives a [__] it's like you got it's cuz
J Leno's collection is different yeah
well that's what I'm saying it's
different it's well curated so that's
the same concept and I feel like you
know um yeah so you know art dealers
they'll their job is to you know talk to
their clientele and and advise them hey
this is this is a market to get into
this work fits in your CL I mean a lot
of it is you know is going to be cookie
cutter and a lot of it is smoking
mirrors
but you know you can make fun of that
[__] cuz you ever see those like parody
videos of like [__] like in an
art gallery and they're saying some
dumbass random [__] about some art
you're know like dude [__]
don't really talk like they do talk like
that sometimes but it's funny you know
and it's silly but that's how it works
so I have a few people who who deal my
stuff on the side and and I don't just
let anybody you know it's people who
have a solid clientele base it's people
that actively working you know I have a
dealer who who has clients all over um
the world and she's she sells my work
pretty um often you know and and she has
clients that I can't reach and I mean
for me I've been fortunate enough to get
hit by a lot of people like the the work
that I've sold over the last few years
is people just hitting me in the DM
being like dude I want to I want to
acquire your work and again in the
beginning it was it was so brand new
that I had to say yes to say no right
you know once I got to say no I would
say it a lot you know what I mean so
like when I did my show last year you
know I had it funny I I had some homeboy
walk in with some hot ass chick you know
and he was like I work with this Gallery
I work with this Gallery how can I you
know get into your work blah I was like
all right well there's a weight list so
if you want to shoot me an email we can
you know evaluate and if you get
approved then we could talk about some
work and he was like no but you know
like I want to like pick up some I was
like n there's a weightless homie I'm
like I'm not going to let you Flex in
front of your girl I was like there's a
weightless if you really want it you'll
hit me up you won't just Flex in front
of your chick cuz if I tell you the
price I doubt you're going to buy so I'm
not going to even humor it um but yeah
so it's you know in the beginning um you
know I said yes a lot and uh yeah you
know dealers are cool you know they they
get the work out there
but again I F for me it's I've been
fortunate enough to to do a lot of [__]
on my own and wear that hat where people
could just hit me up and be like you
know I want to I want to acquire or
something and then and then we go about
it if the for you how how cuz you know
you just did the Jay worthy Kamaya album
cover for you how often are you getting
hit to do album covers cuz you just said
you you said earlier that you said no
you know to somebody I mean I get I get
hit up by a lot of upcoming artists
artists that haven't like even popped
off I get that all the time um I mean
I've gotten hit up by some pretty big
people you know I I I mean not to name
drop but you know over the last year I
was talking to Meek Mill about doing a
with him yeah it would be gamechanging
um so you know [__] like that is you
know it comes around you know pey hit me
up on just some I'm trying to collect
some art [__] I want some [__] on my
crib exactly you know what I mean he I
mean he's a fan of Wes like everybody
else so everybody wants to acquire when
when Wes really paved like the
groundwork and like put a lot of rap
[__] on especially it just into
the art [__] period yeah you know cuz
you have a lot of rappers that have been
collecting art you know um cause statue
well yeah you know Swiss beats has a
real [__] swis ho there's like those
there's a few select few that really
have jz's collection is not even
comparable that he's got [__] bats
and [__] like his [__] is Blue Chip art
I'm talking about like I mean Swiss
beats work is even you know pretty close
up there but I mean Jay-Z's probably got
the best collection in the rap game as
far as rappers go for sure you know him
Kanye swiz is right up there and then
Wes is Wes has got a lot of [__] art
a lot of it I like how like he'll like
you know uh gravitate to like a
independent small painter like yourself
or or what's her name Mariel Mariel yeah
Mariela squat Dead face Kip yeah you
like if you just go to his like you know
when we went to a spot in Buffalo it was
just like it was like it was like it's
it's literal Gallery but you know I
think Wes Wes has a Keen Eye for what he
likes he I don't think he cares whether
something there's certain things that he
he doesn't really uh care about like the
name behind it if it's dope and that
shit's raw speaks to him he's in he's
going to [__] with it and I think that
that's how he really operates like that
when it comes to Art and curating things
obviously when it's like when he's on
his fashion drip like he's going to be
wearing like the creme de creme you know
the best [__] that money can buy you
know but with art he's got a vision and
if it speaks to him he's going to run
with it and that's been kind of his his
genius because you know look how many
artists he's worked with I mean I'm not
going to sit here and toot my my horn
but obviously I
think I don't even think I know I mean
I've done the most [__] with him because
it's gets to this it's a come to this
point where whenever Wes is working on a
project or anything the fans expect him
to do [__] with me right they're like
waiting like when and then you pray for
me came out there was a bunch of people
in the comments like y are we getting
alter art from Isaac you know so it's
like they kind of expect it right
because we've done so much projects
together that people can't separate my
work from his work they they they want
the two together they're in tune so it's
really hard for them to hear the music
without seeing some polio [__] go along
with it they want the merch they want
the prints they want the vinyls or the
cassettes no the merch goes crazy I see
that [__] everywhere I was going to say
for you uh let everybody know just kind
of cuz people are going to watch this
they're going to want to know where they
can buy cuz you said you have some stuff
on RT yeah I mean all my [__] is going
to be listed in my my Instagram my bio
you know my website's there I'm always
putting out prints and merch I have you
know there's there's my orig I have a
lot of original work available on RSC
there's a lot of stuff that's not even
online they got to sort of hit me up and
right you know sometimes I'll I'll bring
people over to my studio kind of show
them around give them a tour of what's
not even online you know what I'm saying
you know I'm working on three exhibits
right now I'm working on an exhibit um a
private exhibit for a members Club in
Downtown LA for uh this month I'm
working on another exhibit in Boston and
then I'm working on a solo show for next
year in New York oh fire that's the
first time I just brought that up so in
New York so you're already kind of do
you like when you do that and you know
you have three shows coming up are you
going to like it's almost like when you
create an album do you know like okay
this is for Boston this is for New York
I'm already curating it like that like
I'm already I've for for the last 6
months I've been developing a new body
of work um kind of pushing everything
that I've been doing and trying to take
you know put it uh take it to a new give
it a new identity push the envelope and
hopefully you know people respond to it
well um I'll rotate you know like some
of the [__] that I had in my last show
I'll probably exhibit in Boston because
there's people there who hadn't seen
that stuff so I'll introduce them to
that work and I'll just kind of rotate
and curate things a certain way um the
exhibit that I have at the private
members Club there'll be an ex an
opening uh next year in January that's
going to be featuring work that's never
been seen before obviously for the solo
show in New York that's going to be
brand new work that no one's ever seen
before I haven't even started on that
work yet and I actually have my dad um
featuring an exclusive uh exhibit work
as well yeah I yeah I he's going to be
exhibiting like maybe like five dad
Antonio Antonio pal fire so it's going
to be dope um I'm excited to put that
out there I mean I just did but
officially you know roll out and start
inviting in New York it's going to be
June 6th oh so you got Manhattan 6
months well seven months yeah yeah yeah
yeah but um that's dope man congrats
yeah thank you it's going to be it's
going to be lit you know it's um going
to be presented by in magazine so
they're backing it fire yeah man here it
is man well I appreciate you pulling up
brother thanks for having me go follow
this guy go buy some prints you just
dropped the Tupac prints are there any
available or they sold out sh sold out
dunzo okay well there'll be there'll be
some more prints of something coming
yeah I got some [__] I got some an
extension of that drop coming out um I
think next month so you know if they
didn't get an opportun they didn't get
an opportunity to uh cop that [__] they
you know they can get an opportunity to
cop some other [__] last question I
always am curious yeah how do you scan a
painting you can do the print well
there's scanners out there that you know
scan super high res but I don't have
that [__] I don't have a that's you know
that [__] cost that cost a lot of money
but there's other ways to go about it
you know sometimes you can take a
highres photograph um I used to have a
guy years ago I used to have a guy that
would photograph my my pencil drawings
and color correct it make make it a
super highr tip file that um was good
for printing and then eventually I
started taking photos of my own work so
everything that's shot all the prints
that's just me taking a high-risk
photograph of it and then cleaning it up
in like Photoshop yeah make it printable
that's yeah even all I always wondered
that cuz I was like yo like when people
do prints like where are these scanners
at yeah well you know the especially the
large paintings you know like things
that are super huge that that's taken
with a super highres camera where
there's you got to be a specific angle
so it's flat yeah you know the lighting
has got to be like in a black room so
there's no um you know light reflection
and you you see like you know so it's
there's ways to to do it that's probably
the most efficient way when you're
taking pictures of large works I mean
I'm going to keep it real I take all my
[__] on my iPhone really yeah yeah but
you know I'm I I took like six months in
Photoshop so I clean my [__] up really
well which iPhone 15 no I have the I
have the I think I have the 13 yeah so
you got to get you a 15 I know I got to
update my [__] you know what I'm saying
but yeah there's ways to to do it all
those files that Wes has you know that's
just me taking the photos myself
cleaning it up making sure that it's at
the highest anbum yeah yeah and make
sure it's there's no glares or any type
of like you know just weird weird
imperfections in the photo so well now
you know yeah I mean you know people
don't people don't know how to do that
[__] and that's part of you know being
really embedded and wearing all those
hats so yeah get your [__] up get your
[__] up out there man Isaac I appreciate
you brother thank you so much for having
me Big Dog boom fire yo we're wrapping
up an interview man of course we want to
shout out to our family at harden baby
Harden Las Vegas celebrating their
seventh birthday this month so happy
birthday to harden uh want to give a
shout out to the whole family over there
when you're in Las Vegas you got to pull
up to harden tell them that the bootle C
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the merch you know what I'm
saying and it's right in Las Vegas right
in s City so you land in Vegas you about
to go gamble with your boys you get in
that cab you say take me to harden
they're going to know exactly where to
take you all right shout out to harden
go follow him Harden Las Vegas or go to
the website Hardin vegas.com